[Aplausos]
hoy hablaremos de dos temas que
aparentemente no tienen mucha relación
entre sí
la confianza y la tecnología
y como esta última está transformando
radicalmente el concepto de la confianza
y la manera en que las personas se
relacionan entre sí
la confianza es fundamental para
establecer cualquier tipo de relaciones
gracias a ella se construyen los hogares
las empresas las sociedades
yo tengo que confiar en ti para poder
intercambiar bienes conocimientos
sentimientos
de acuerdo a la investigadora de la
colaboración rachel bootsma no la
confianza ha evolucionado en tres etapas
local institucional y distribuida
nos embarcamos en un momento en que
hemos dejado de confiar en las
instituciones que constantemente nos
fallan para empezar a confiar en los
extraños
estamos trasladando la confianza a
nuestra confianza desde el ámbito
institucional hacia el ámbito
distribuido que es compatible con el
mundo digital
cuando las sociedades de las más
pequeñas
sus miembros podían intercambiar valor y
llegar a acuerdos con relativa facilidad
porque se conocían entre sí
si alguno de ellos actuaba
deshonestamente era probable que el
resto lo llegue a saber
perjudicándose seriamente su reputación
conforme las sociedades crecieron y las
distancias se hicieron más grandes así
también lo hizo la incertidumbre
con la creación de instituciones que son
las llamadas a actuar de intermediarios
de confianza entre las personas se logró
reducir esta incertidumbre a niveles
tolerables
sin embargo tanto en instituciones
públicas como privadas nos han venido
fallando consistentemente debido a su
estructura rígida jerárquica
centralizada y muchas veces obsoleta
la centralización y la acumulación de
poder generan corrupción
el día de hoy estoy aquí para hablarles
sobre la cadena de bloques
una de las tecnologías subyacentes de
bitcoin y otras cripto monedas
que tiene aplicaciones que van más allá
del dinero todas ellas relacionadas con
la confianza con la confianza
distribuida
lo fascinante de los nuevos inventos y
paradigmas
es que resulta extremadamente difícil
pronosticar el impacto que tendrán en el
futuro
sus implicaciones se van descubriendo
sobre la marcha al cabo de décadas
muchas veces
con el fin de predecir el impacto que un
paradigma tendrá
es necesario que nos hagamos la
siguiente pregunta
cuál es el espacio o el vacío que este
nuevo paradigma ayuda a llenar
en el siglo 15 con la invención de la
imprenta se llenó el vacío del
conocimiento poniéndose a disposición de
todos libros repletos de sabiduría que
antes estaban en manos únicamente de
ciertos privilegiados
con la invención de la máquina de vapor
en el siglo 19 se trasladó el trabajo
manual hacia el mecánico
llenándose el vacío de poder
en términos de energía y fuerza
necesarias para la producción de bienes
en serie la esencia de la revolución
industrial
ya en el siglo 20 en la década de 1970
apareció el invento favorito de todos en
internet
llenando el vacío de la distancia
reduciendo el tamaño del mundo
permitiendo que nos comuniquemos casi
gratis e instantáneamente sin importar
dónde nos encontramos y por supuesto que
podamos compartir videos y memes de
gatitos en las redes sociales
en 2009 fuimos testigos de la aparición
de una nueva propuesta tecnológica que
ofrece llenar el vacío de la confianza
así como el internet transformó
radicalmente a las comunicaciones
poniéndolas al alcance de todos
democratizando las
la cadena de bloques ahora lo mismo con
las instituciones sociales políticas y
económicas
block change es una base de datos
abierta sin fronteras distribuida
neutral y resistente a la censura que
almacena y mueve todo tipo de datos
incluyendo activos dinero acciones
certificados títulos música fotografía
etcétera
no es más que un gran libro contable
cuyos asientos o transacciones se
encuentran almacenados en una estructura
secuencial de bloques
ordenada cronológicamente y relacionada
entre sí matemáticamente
la gran innovación es que estos datos
que se encuentran contenidos en los
bloques no pueden ser borrados o
modificados sin el consenso de la
participa de los de todos los
participantes de la red informática
llamados nodos
por ejemplo la brocha interior está
conformada por 17.500 nodos distribuidos
alrededor del mundo
cuando hacemos cualquier tipo de
transacción
partimos de la premisa de que no podemos
confiar en la otra parte
por eso es necesaria la participación de
intermediarios que verifiquen y
certifican que lo que la otra parte nos
está diciendo es verdad
los registros que actualmente utilizamos
para verificar y respaldar las
transacciones que realizamos como por
ejemplo comprar una casa o un auto son
fácilmente manipulables porque porque
son gestionados centralizadamente
hace un mes me encontraba en lima
asistiendo a una reunión con uno de los
fundadores de la empresa italiana a la
que represento
esta organización es una de las pioneras
en el desarrollo e implementación de
sistemas inmutables de trazabilidad
basados en block change
fuimos a un restaurante conocido y
disfrutamos de un exquisito ceviche sólo
con recordarlo se me hace agua la boca
al momento de pagar en efectivo el
cajero hizo el clásico gesto de tomar
los billetes ponerlos a contraluz y
estirar los casi hasta romperlos con el
fin de comprobar su autenticidad
en respuesta a este ritual uno de mis
socios le dijo al cajero que quería ver
el pescado con el que había sido
fabricado preparar perdón preparado el
ceviche
que quería conocer si era un producto
nacional o extranjero
si es que había sido pescado o criado en
granja
en qué condiciones había sido almacenado
y transportado
y cuál era la ruta que había seguido
hasta llegar a nuestros platos
pregunta super incómoda cierto este es
el tipo de cliente que ningún
restaurante quisiera tener
el cajero se quedó perplejo fue a llamar
al jefe de los meseros quien se acercó a
nosotros muy amablemente y nos preguntó
si había algún problema con la comida o
con el servicio mi socio volvió a
hacerle las mismas preguntas
el mesero nos dijo que era coordina
fresca del día y que había sido comprada
al proveedor habitual
mi socio le dijo muy bien tú nos estás
diciendo que es así pero quiero que me
lo demuestre con pruebas con evidencias
con documentos
porque si el ceviche que yo he comido el
día de hoy me causa graves problemas
estomacales no tengo a quien reclamar no
tengo a quien responsabilizar por los
perjuicios ocasionados
ante este escenario
cuál fue la moraleja que nos quedó
fuimos testigos de que existe un gran
vacío de confianza a lo largo de la
cadena de suministro
los consumidores estamos a merced de las
buenas y malas decisiones que toman
quienes producen fabrican y nos venden
los diferentes productos
la poca información a la que tenemos
acceso no es transparente
y desconocemos casi por completo de los
procesos involucrados en la fabricación
de los alimentos que nos llevamos a la
boca
ante esta situación quiero plantear las
siguientes preguntas
conocemos el origen y los ingredientes
de los alimentos que consumimos
puede estar seguro que una lata de atún
viene de ecuador y que su pesca no
proviene de áreas protegidas
cómo puedo saber si el pollo que estoy
comiendo ha cumplido con las normativas
sanitarias y de bienestar animal a lo
largo de su crianza y faenamiento
tengo la certeza de que los tomates que
he comprado son orgánicos tal y como
dice en su etiqueta
no nos queda más que confiar
a pesar de que el 20% del vino que se
vende en el mundo es falsificado entre
el 60 y el 90 por ciento del aceite de
oliva está adulterado con otros aceites
pasta y arroz hechos de plástico y
parafina jugos de fruta que no contienen
fruta
carne en estado de putrefacción que es
maquillada con químicos cancerígenos
para que parezca fresca
el fraude y la falsificación en la
industria alimenticia representa el 10
por ciento de los más de 150 mil
millones de dólares que genera cada año
lo mismo ocurre en otras importantes
industrias farmacéutica cosmética
tecnológica automovilística
la falsificación y la piratería es un
negocio de 300 mil millones de dólares
al año
la globalización de los mercados ha
hecho que las cadenas de suministro sean
cada vez más largas y mientras más
extensas se vuelve más complicado
controlarlas y asegurar las siendo más
probable que se cometan errores de buena
fe y por supuesto engaños y fraudes
la cadena de bloques se ayuda a resolver
este problema dotando a los datos de una
dimensión de confianza por sí mismos
recordándoles que la información que se
encuentra almacenada en una bloc cheng
no puede ser borrada o modificada por
tanto no se requiere de intermediarios
que lo certifiquen como auténtica
es un hecho que en el corto plazo
regulaciones tanto europeas como
estadounidenses exigirán la
implementación de sistemas inmutables de
trazabilidad a quienes pretendan
exportar sus productos a estas regiones
existe una gran preocupación por la
seguridad e inocuidad de los alimentos
así como por la salud pública
ahora bien ustedes se preguntarán qué es
eso de la trazabilidad
es una serie de procedimientos que nos
permiten conocer el origen la historia
la ubicación y la trayectoria de un
producto a lo largo de la cadena de
suministro a través del uso de ciertas
herramientas tecnológicas
actualmente la trazabilidad se realiza
con medios informáticos convencionales
es decir gestionados centralizadamente
cerradamente que carecen de la apertura
y la transparencia de la cadena de
bloques
en este sentido blog change representa
un factor disruptivo tanto en la traza
de trazabilidad como en muchos otros
ámbitos
ahora quiero contarles lo que estamos
haciendo en el perú a través de una
plataforma de origen italiano basada en
blogging estamos implementando sistemas
inmutables de trazabilidad para los
sectores agroindustrial textil y
aduanero
el primer caso tiene que ver con el
pisco esa deliciosa bebida espirituosa
peruana hecha de uva levanten la mano a
quien le gusta el pisco
a mí me encanta
el fabricante quiere transparentar y
sincerar sus procesos productivos frente
a los consumidores y a las autoridades
cada botella de pisco
tendrá un código qr único en su etiqueta
que puede ser escaneado con cualquier
celular este código nos llevará a una
página web dinámica que nos cuenta toda
la historia de cada una de las botellas
si alguien en la audiencia tiene un
lector de códigos le pido que escanee el
código qr en pantalla ahora bien que nos
cuenta qué historia nos cuenta este
código
nos puede nos permite conocer el origen
del pisco en qué país en qué región en
qué provincia en qué ciudad en qué
viñedo fue producido qué variedad o
variedades de uva se utilizaron para esa
fabricación cuales agroquímicos y en qué
dosis se aplicaron durante todo el ciclo
productivo en qué fecha fue la cosecha
en qué barril fue almacenado el pisco en
qué fecha fue embotellado
cuántos litros de agua se consumieron
durante su fabricación y cuál fue la
ruta que siguió cada una de las botellas
desde que salió de la fábrica hasta
llegar a los diferentes puntos de venta
el segundo caso tiene que ver
con la lucha contra la contra el
contrabando y la falsificación de
licores importados
en conjunto con una entidad estatal
peruana estamos desarrollando un plan
piloto de trazabilidad inmutable de
licores importados
cada botella de ron whisky cerveza y
otros licores así mismo llevará un
código qr en su etiqueta el cual nos
contará la historia de esa botella en
particular cuál es su origen en qué
punto ingreso al territorio peruano cómo
fue transportada vía terrestre vía
marítima vía aérea qué documentos
tributarios y aduaneros se generaron
durante el proceso de importación
y cuál es la ruta que esa botella siguió
desde su origen hasta llegar a los
diferentes puntos de venta
entonces
block change puede ser utilizada para
cualquier cosa que requiera de
validación certificación y garantía de
ejecución sin la participación de un
intermediario de confianza mi sueño es
ver un mundo más libre próspero honesto
y justo gracias a la cadena de bloques
lo podemos lograr
producción de alimentos limpia y honesta
agricultores que reciben un pago justo
por sus productos
mercados sin intermediarios que conectan
directamente a productores con
consumidores
y consumidores que tienen acceso a
información transparente y fiables los
productos que adquieren creadores de
contenidos escritores músicos fotógrafos
que reciben compensaciones adecuadas por
su trabajo
elecciones
transparentes libres de fraude
auditables públicamente en tiempo real y
resistentes a los apagones
volviendo al vacío de confianza que
existe entre los proveedores y
consumidores la cadena de bloques es una
herramienta tecnológica que contribuye a
la recuperación ya la consolidación de
la confianza a través de la imposición
de la honestidad y la transparencia
entre los diferentes actores de la
cadena de suministro para concluir
quiero decir que los paradigmas
políticos sociales y económicos tienen
fecha de caducidad funcionan bien
durante un tiempo luego empiezan a
fallar se nos puede ajustar pero luego
tarde o temprano deben ser reemplazados
por otros porque se vuelven obsoletos
tengo la firme convicción de que la
cadena de bloques es ese nuevo paradigma
gracias
[Aplausos]